my guests have most likely animated a
good chunk of your childhood from an
American tale to land before time to
seek review in to Anastasia just to name
a few
they've also animated innovative games
like dragon's lair and Space Ace they
have written several books and taught
several classes on the art of animation
and they're in the process of creating
another hand-drawn animated film that
you can help bring to life with dragon's
lair the movie it is a pleasure to
welcome to Animation Giants Don Bluth
and Gary Goldman how are you - you're
good I'm fine but I'm only five foot two
and he's four feet I think that's it is
it's really not Giants I don't usually
do this I'm going to start off with a
question from my fans this is the most
requested question that they wanted me
to ask you after watching my reviews of
some of your films why haven't you
killed me yet why haven't we you know
what it's just a reverse dagger if you
win Rondo the truth is reversed I've I'm
such a I have taken such a liking to
your cutting style that I'm trying to
get that in everything we do now I loved
what you're cutting Wow that is the last
thing I expected you to say no I like it
you know why linger on an image any
longer than a nanosecond I don't get it
you know it's good to do what you're
doing it could be a good idea to kill
him they would send us to jail we get a
lot more important that this one stay
alive okay the dafu productions had a
real mafia thing going I had no idea it
would we'll start right at the beginning
uh you both started working at Disney
for several other films got this style
that is very similar to what they did
this beautiful smooth style what drew
you to animation and particularly that
kind of style I think those moments in
your childhood you know when you see
something for the first time I think
that leaves an impression on you I know
it did on me and after seeing some of
these Disney films first one being Snow
White it left something an impression
that I really love the experience and I
keep wanting to see it and I knew the
name Walt Disney so I wanted to go back
and see everything that he did and
time it was that same wonderful feeling
the colors perhaps it had to do with the
the musical imagery because animation is
sort of like music and I and I salute to
that as you grow older that just remains
with you and you seem to capture early
what you're going to behave like later
on I started off wanting to be a panel
artist for Dennis the Menace in in the
papers I met a guy once and he actually
sent me into animation within I think
six weeks of after meeting dawn there in
Disney they showed us Pinocchio
I was so awestruck by the imagery on the
screen as I started coming to work at
6:00 in the morning and not leaving till
eight o'clock at night I wanted to be
there you want you've animated and you
you flip the drawings you know you see
those pages one of the time going by and
those images then seem to come to life
that is a buzz it's really a magical
feeling and I know the poor guys who are
over there and the gals who work in CG
don't quite get that same buzz it's a
it's just a real feeling I mean why do
people like that I don't know but it's
it's something that once it gets in your
blood you love it you literally start
your own animation studio after working
with Disney in your garage and even
though you had worked with the biggest
name in animation with Walt Disney
Studios what made you both want to leave
and pursue your own studio we were being
trained to be animators and at the same
time management telling us that you know
within six years these masters are going
to reserve and retire and you need to be
ready to take on the helm Don came up
with he says look you know this isn't
going to happen just here why don't we
go to my house and we'll we'll do a
short film and we'll learn a lot faster
there was no one there really who was
going to be a director we're all
learning how to animate but how do you
put a picture together so that none of
that was being trained and no one seemed
to be a bit alarmed that fact you know
that we weren't learning fast enough to
replace the old guard everything in the
in the studio was Union controlled we
couldn't use any of the cameras or
anything like that to experiment so the
only way we could experiment was to get
outside the reaches of that
Union by our own equipment and then just
feel free to explore and in exploring we
found out things that we really needed
to know like the straw that broke the
camel's back with me was in rescuers I
believe it was where they'd even paint
the white of the eye in the little mouse
anymore it was just all the same colors
the skin cuz that drove me nuts too I'm
glad that drove you insane cuz I
remember seeing that movie and I'm like
why aren't their eyes white there's a
comforter fur so I'm so glad that drove
you insane too because that drove me
nuts yes it did me too and so I said
well wait a minute that doesn't make any
sense why do you say that it's too
expensive to do the things that made on
the screen beautiful so in in
experimenting out in the garage what
came about is we found out that it
wasn't too expensive they were just
saying that and I guess they were saying
that something had told them from
upstairs so we went back and said to
them hey you know we thought that we can
do this innocently we said that and they
said oh you guys need to just be still
just do it rest
eventually the audience is going to
catch on and see that it's good cheaper
looking you're getting a cheaper product
you know Walt was once quoted as saying
the worst thing that I ever did if the
studio was to go public and when you go
public of course you had stockholders
now you have to please all of those
people I think were he there at the time
you know when we were all there if he
were there I think it probably wouldn't
have gone in that direction
he was already heading out into
animatronics and all kinds of things you
know with Disneyland but and I was there
and Sleeping Beauty when he was building
Disneyland in Anaheim so we didn't see
him at the studio too often but I think
he would have been a pioneer and he
would have seen that the pictures were
losing their luster one of the things
that circulate for a little bit I always
want to figure out this was true there
was a rumor that you Don said that you
can show children almost anything as
long as there's a happy ending first of
all is there a truth to saying that in
second even if there isn't do you
believe kind of that mindset because
your films did go very dark and many
times you don't show the darkness you
don't appreciate the light if it weren't
for December no one would appreciate May
it's just important that you see Bo
sides of that and as far as a happy
ending
I believe the happy ending is important
if you really want to have mothers have
their children go see it and if they
themselves will go but there's more to
it than that I think more importantly is
that when you walk out of the theater
there's something that you have that you
get to take home what did it teach me
what do am I better person for having
watched it and I think Walt was very
very much in that in that groove trying
to say something and I could tell it
from his films you know that he was a
moral guy and he was really trying to
say something that would connect with
with a nation that had morals nowadays
I'm not sure what's being produced and
whether it has you know it has something
to say or not I'm just not sure I had a
little bit of problem which I probably
shouldn't talk about I have a little bit
problem with inside out I think it's
because the little girl never did
anything on her own without little
gremlins up in her head telling her what
to feel I'd rather say you're in control
you decide what you want to be you
decide whether you're going to go right
or left and that's important you have
worked with several great actors uh both
very well-known and very very under the
radar but definitely wonderful wonderful
performers who are your favorite actors
that you've ever worked with in terms of
animation and without a blush I can tell
you that would be Angela Lansbury this
is a woman that you know her persona on
screen and on stage you would never
suspect she's a very very humble lady
and and eager to please and to help
whatever she can and this is the part
that was the clincher for me she didn't
go out and buy fancy lunches every day
she brought her own little brown peg
lunch and I've had I've had two so
feeling Carol Channing ah she was
wonderful she is willing to do anything
to help speaking of which you have also
worked with some of the greatest
composers uh the music in your films I
always feel is the one thing that seems
almost just as phenomenal as the
animation because you work with
composers like James Horner ranked Jerry
Goldsmith what was it like working with
these great musicians and how did you
manage to get such a great sound out of
them because the music in your movies
are just always phenomenal Jerry
Goldsmith in the Ben
he a close friend he had told us he was
going to do a sweeping score he says I'm
not going to do some Mickey Mouse thing
like they did over Disney and as he got
into it and he was watching the
animation he's called and he says I
don't think I'm going to be doing a
sweeping score he says you seem to have
a rhythm going on and the rhythm changes
and stuff in the animation the way the
characters are walking in tempos they're
they're I don't want to dismiss those
those are musical the same thing from
Jamie Horner he saw the same things in
it
we had just signed Jerry to dudes secret
of NIMH and we started getting a call
from James Horner's agent and he says
you know you guys need to hire James
Horner and he's the next Jerry Goldsmith
I said but we have Jerry Goldsmith at
least three weeks he called me once a
week to see if he couldn't talk me out
of of Jerry Goldsmith because we could
get Jerry or James Horner for a lot
cheaper and I said no no that we're
happy with Jerry you know and it was
very next picture that we did feature
with americantale Jerry was supposed to
do the movie and Jerry Sara says guys I
have to apologize I said I'll do it and
my agent says I've got six pictures
already for next year and there's no way
I'm going to be able to squeeze this in
James Horner is the one who wrote the
wedding song somewhere out there he
actually did it it was amazing when you
get it - but he he wrote this thing and
Steven Spielberg listened to it and he
said well I don't know it said it but
keep working on it so then he played the
note he played it for a songwriter
lyricist and that would be Barry Mann
and Cynthia Waddell yeah and he played
it for them and very man who has a who
has a voice that a rhino wouldn't like
to have noise so Barry Mann says too
many notes he'd written it kind of like
a little Rondo so when that is so anyway
Barry said how about um ah and with and
with his index finger played the song on
the Fuhrer Joe James and it was really
great university said now that that's
fewer notes it'll probably work that way
I'm assuming he was nama deus fan yeah
well yeah too many notes another fan
requested question that people have been
hounding me to ask you to and I'm quite
curious myself
have either of you ever seen any of the
sequels that have been made from your
movies like secretive NIM to the Land
Before Time sequels americantale to have
any of these ever crossed your paths
I've tried a couple of times and I've
tried to come by try to watch the sequel
to NIM and everything and and I just
felt really really bad you know because
I saw a lot of opportunities that kind
of were missed and I'd like to knock
anybody else's work too much and I tried
to watch even Fievel goes west and
there's those things in it that that
bother me just a little bit and if I
can't track the story at all then you
know I immediately stopped watching
because I like to remember the good part
I like to remember you know how it
really does work and what a good story
can do and how it can change the way you
feel inside I like all that Land Before
Time land how many other going to make
it goes on and on and on so it'd be good
actually if and I don't think we've ever
done a sequel didn't you do Bartok
didn't you do the the Anastasia the bat
one yeah that was because we had nothing
to do it was fine and we had a whole
crew there and so we said well let's
just write a story so we wrote a story
about Baba Yaga the Russian fairy tale
was in Brooklyn which so wrote that
story and tried to just bring the old
character that everybody knew about and
bring him into it and entering him into
the story know what happened was when we
finished Anastasia they did not have a
script ready for us he had two years
actually three years to come up with a
second story how can you not read the
script in three years I don't know but
they didn't deliver it and they said we
don't really know what to give you and
we said what if we come up with an idea
for you know to give you some time and
we came more years bartk and brought in
a writer they didn't know the writer
they didn't ask a thing and he said okay
can you do it for 25 million and we said
yes we can but the only way we could do
it is if we did it in 14 months or less
to get it done for 25 million and all
the accountants at Fox telling us that
you can't do it
everybody makes too much money you'll
never get it for that said we will they
never came to look and it was at the
very end they went they said wow this is
funny
can we put this on the big screen I said
no we cut corners it's not rendered for
for the big screen this is television
you know I actually saw it on TV one
night I was at a convention I saw it on
TV and I'm watching it I'm like you know
that was really a lot of fun I was
unbelievably shocked how much I liked it
cuz it just looked like a basic
straight-to-dvd like those Disney
straight-to-dvd sequels and I'll just
tell you good job on that cuz I thought
was very entertaining thank you good
thank you